de véritables plage en plein centre
ville d'orléans un niveau fluvial
extrêmement bas on n'avait pas vu ça
depuis 2003 l'année de la canicule
ce phénomène d'étiage qui intervient
tous les quatre ans environ peut être
problématique
parmi les concernés les oiseaux en
particulier les sternes
avec tous ces bancs de plage plus
découvert et accessible que d'habitude
leurs yeux se retrouvent à la merci des
prédateurs
autre crainte légitime dans pareil cas
la bonne marche des centrales celles ci
peuvent encore fonctionné sans problème
il existe deux barrages près de roanne
et du puy en velay alimentant des
affluents qui peuvent lâcher de l'oci le
niveau vient à baisser dangereusement
des questions se posent aussi au sujet
du festival de loire à orléans
mais il n'y a aucune inquiétude à avoir
sur le bon déroulement de la fête
seuls des points logistique sont à
revoir ça peut impacter mais c'est trop
tôt pour le dire
les polonais qui nous arrive de cracovie
qu'ont déjà fait 2500 km qui arrive à
briare donc sur le canal de briare et
qui doivent passer en loire
ça peut impacter leur dernier
via tronçon de navigation entre briard
et au relais en revanche on peut
circuler normalement à orléans le lit du
fleuve est une cuvette
là on sait qu'on pourra pas passer
directement sur l'autre bras de loi mais
sur l'autre bras de loire on peut
remonter jusqu'à la partie sablé
jusqu'au port on peut descendre et on
peut remonter jusqu'aux pentes il a donc
je dirais le site du festival il est pas
il est pas un facteur
yves dupont sera fixé définitivement sur
le niveau de la loire quatre jours avant
le début des festivités date à laquelle
les prévisions seront les plus fiables
mais l'édition 2015 devrait se dérouler
sans problème
elle débutera le 23 septembre